the gyro can experience the people that
don't suffer in those communities that
aren't a part of that community there's
a natural inclination to resist no
that's true and it's because they don't
want to do anything they don't they
don't want to think they're responsible
they don't want to think they're a part
of it they don't want to discuss it even
discussing it you feel resistance they
will in the state of denial yes trying
to avoid and trying to evade no it's
it's very it's very real that's very
real but you know it also works within
communities of people of color and this
is again why I think we have to resist
any monolithic care or homogenious
characterizations of people see so they
need time to talk about white supremacy
you've got the John Brown's and you know
Mary Ellen Pleasant was the a black
woman who was worth 347 million dollars
in the 1840s whoa she's called the
mother of human rights in Calif
he made a rich white brother and he died
I don't know what millions of dollars
first thing she did she gave John Brown
a million dollars Wow John Brown hasn't
even noticed from her in his pocket when
he was at Harpers Ferry that's how he
survived see now John Brown was killed
innocent people I think that's wrong I
don't believe in innocent people no
matter who they are no matter what color
but at the same time John Brown had a
love of black people much deeper too
many black people have of themselves
because he's willing to die for black
people but the same is true with in
let's say black communities you've got
ok 1 percent of the population in
America who own 41 percent of the wealth
you got three individuals who have
wealth the equivalent to 160 million
fellow citizens but within the black
community the top 1% of black folk and
what was 70 percent of the wealth so
that means you got a lot of precious
Jamal's and the teachers out there who
don't who are told to live vicariously
through the lives of black celebrities
so it's all about representation rather
than substantive transformation you get
that in politicians you know you got a
black president
all of y'all must be free
isn't that a beautiful thing live
through him live through the family
beautiful achievement magnificent
achievement but it's not about symbolic
representation only this is about
fundamental transformation so it's a
challenge Mary Ellen Pleasant and others
in Martin King and others are challenges
for those of us who do have some
resources to still raise our voices
because you can be black highly
well-adjusted the injustice economically
in terms of race and so forth and the
same is true you can be brown you can be
rich
so it's not just a matter of looking for
that one individual who represents it's
a matter of connecting that
representation to fundamental
transformation if there's no fundamental
transformation you end up with a whole
generation of peacocks look at me look
at me look at me all about forage and
what does that do that falls directly
into the culture of superficial
spectacle yeah last thing we need is
just spectacle with no substance in that
way and this is the battle within within
the communities of peoples of color
because it's not it's not gonna be a
matter of just pointing out white
supremacy of course white supremacy is
fundamental foundation in part of the
country it's not the only foundation
because you got resistance to white
supremacy Lydia Maria child she wrote a
book in 1834 called an appeal but that
class of Americans called Africans it
was deeply influenced by one of the
greatest works ever written at that time
by David Walker appealed the colored
citizens of the world she's a wife
sister she is as vanilla as Doris Day in
the eighteen thirties fundamental part
of the black freedom movement right but
you see those folks need to be lifted up
because what does that do that exposes
our humanity in terms of the choices we
make not just the skin color we have
and I would say the same thing in terms
of gender the brothers who are
fundamentally concerned about breaking
the back of patriarchy when we know
patriarchy is shot to us because we grew
up in the 1950s and 60s no man escapes
it but you try to recon at all and the
same is true our precious gays and
lesbians and transphobia see to be
decent human beings who make moral
choices you I believe in the primacy of
the moral and the spiritual the
centrality of the artistic especially
the musical and especially the comics as
the vanguard who represent a freedom and
a courage and a vision to connect us as
human beings because you can't really be
a comic with a wholesale Nazi ideology
now you can be a Nazi genius like Martin
Heidegger who was a great philosopher
and a genius and a Doug when it comes to
pop when it comes to politics you see
but a comic has got to be able to be
open enough to deal with the incongruity
and inconsistency and the sheer
absurdity of it all you talked about
moments of freedom earlier and I
recognize that is like one of the
greatest things you ever see when
someone's onstage and they're killing
there's moments where everyone's
together they're all together locked up
in the laughter and they're all together
there's a sense of community that you
share with the people that are in the
room absolutely it does bring people
together even if it's for brief moments
for a few seconds or a little bit saw
statements are not to be trashed life
consistent moment yes you know what at
me yes definitely and it's in a
democracy you see it's those moments
that constitute the memory of what could
be yeah as opposed to what's in place
you know the great August Wilson the
great playwright of black playwright
deeply influenced he said by the Blues
Baraka and beard and a row man be
written the great painter Mary Baraka of
course from Newark like yourself is like
Sarah Vaughan and Philip Roth right
they're from Newark he used to say that
performance authorized
alternative realities for the audience
that gets them to unsettle their
conventional perceptions of the world
whoa and that's what great artists and
great comics but that's what that's what
you do yeah that's you do strange times
oh brother
[Applause]